james caprilian making his 16th start
of the season remember
he also made two starts against the
texas rangers back to back first one on
august 8th and then again august 14th
in that final game five in the third
innings just three runs
and the right-hander kicks deals the
first pitch of the game and it's drilled
to center marte goes back
moves into left center just a little bit
lamont way junior goes after the first
pitch
he's retired and that's out number one
very tough guy to strike out
[Applause]
and speaking of he does strike out off
speed pitch capralian gets him out in
front
[Applause]
a check swing soft line drive into the
glove of elvis anders and it's a good
first inning for james capralian bottom
of the first coming up
taking them out for the giants across
the bay is alex wood coming on for the
22nd start of the season done a great
job bouncing back 10-3 record you see it
there 121 strikeouts in 115 innings
and that is all for canna
strike three
he got the high strike there
and much like caprelli and you're seeing
alex good would go right to the breaking
stuff early
right center for you medium deep yes
crawling off wade inning over
bell 240 and 16 homer's 36 rbis he's
been scuffling
and the veteran at the plate the pitch
by caprilion has swung on a fly ball
left field playable cannon is about two
steps toward the line waiting for the
ball to come down and that's that number
one
[Applause]
swinging a miss he struck him out at a
high breaking ball
maybe not where caprilian wanted it but
it worked yeah but you know what just
like on the golf course kite you will
take a miss hit that ends up on the
green
every time
alex dickerson josh harrison's out in
shallow right field from second base
now a swing and a little blue broken bat
shallow center it's gonna fall base hit
crawford to second he'll stop there
so the bat exploded but alex dickerson
gets a two out single two on two out
and that one is driven marty on the run
marty on the run martay makes a terrific
running catch in deep left center field
see how he's just shaded a little bit
toward right center
he's got to go
got to get into the left center he's got
to go back a long ways as well
jed lowry first pitch swinging in the
bottom of the second a high fly ball
left field chris bryant underneath it
he'll make the catch
slowly hit up the third base line flores
is gonna let it go
well one umpire says fair the other one
says foul
so now they're going to have to have a
discussion because the home plate um
part ripper pointed fair the third base
umpire tom hallian pointed foul
so it's going to be
a base hit
for jan gomes
and he blows a fastball by him strike
three
on the inner third
first and third and the uh return to the
fold of pinder
two and two two on two out and the
fastball and he chased
another 2-2 caprilion to ushromski
swing a domestic fastball away at 93.
third k for cap
swinging a liner into the shift short
hop picked and dropped by harrison
regains the handle hustles an underhand
toss to olson for round number two
two on two out of brandon belt comes up
in a spot where he could really do some
damage but
two on two out three and one
and ball four too high he has walked the
bases loaded and now chris bryant
strides to the plate with the bases
loaded
bryant
towards center marte backs up and martay
grabs it
and caprilian walks three and they all
get stranded no score bottom of the
third coming up
[Applause]
taps slowly
will flores on the bare hand the throw
got him
phil cuzzy is the first base umpire and
looks like they may take a look at it
yeah he did look safe there i got him
safe
good effort by wilmer this is the only
play he has go to the bare hand i'd like
to say this shouldn't take too long
and it won't
he's going to be safe
but alex will take it
fly ball to left and caught by bryant
right towards second throw to first now
back to second and they got him a double
play
what his job is right after that get rid
of this ball and who's waiting matt
chapman get somewhere
so one away here's harrison josh
harrison dropped a single
into right field his first and bad boy
he would take that here pitch the jay
hey swing a liner in the center it's a
base hit here comes lowry behind him as
gomes the throw home by yustrepski not
in time in the second base sliding is
jay hay and it's two nothing oakland
so here's kenna he's looking for a two
out hit
that is called strike three right on the
inside
mike kastrepski stands in against
caprilian
into his wind up the 1-2 pitch
fastball there's a shot high and deep to
right field way back there
goodbye
and listen to the giants fans take over
the coliseum now 19th home run of the
year for yaz
and that was a long one
well that was a two-seamer that came
back out toward the middle of the plate
and yes did not miss that one he'd love
to tack on an insurance run after a big
two-out knock starling took strike three
and what he thought were questionable
pitches in both the first and third
another 2-2
long look now he deals
and that is fair down the first base
line ken is going to come in to score
marty digging for second and he's going
to hold up there a huge two-out hit by
starling marty and it's three to one
left on left against matt olsen who's
old for five lifetime against them marty
takes off and he is gonna be safe the
ball rolls down the third base line and
marty's gonna come in and score alvarez
had him at third and he threw it away
tonight wilmer flores will try to keep
this game going and forest it's a ground
ball to short elvis to his left flipping
the second in time for the force and the
asm won it
and he is winning using
a lot of different ways to get it done
[Applause]